As we close out the course, we thought it might be useful to go over some lighting terminology
and the types of lighting so that it gives you a better idea about this PBR workflow
and how you can use it in your scenes.
So the topics will cover the lighting definitions and the behavior of the lights, we'll talk
about static versus dynamic and the different light types you can have in your scenes.
So lighting terminology, we essentially have three different types of lighting definitions
and behaviors.
We have the direct lighting, we have indirect or bounce lighting and then the shadows.
So if you look at our top right hand image here, the direct lighting, you'll see that
the light is directly falling upon the surface without any interference and the light travels
directly to the surface that the surface receives the full color of spectrum of light.
So the indirect lighting therefore is if you drop down and you see the second image, you'll
see that there's some indirect lighting going on just on the underside of that surface.
So lighting that has been reflected by other surfaces nearby, as light bounces off these
surfaces, light waves are absorbed or reflected based on the surface properties and passed
onto the surface you are looking at.
So indirect lighting contributes to the mood and overall light intensity.
So when you have this balance between not only the direct lighting and the indirect
lighting, you get a much nicer result.
But then let's talk about these shadows a little bit on the underside here.
So shadows happen when Unreal Engine takes a snapshot of a mesh actor from the light's
point of view and projects that information onto another mesh on the opposite side.
So we still have control and functionality assigned to shadows and we can change the
properties of shadows inside the engine as well.
So that's just an overview of the different types of lighting we're looking at.
So when we're talking about static versus dynamic lighting, we have a few different
options available here.
So the bait lighting is pre-computed rendered lighting.
So we bake lighting using Unreal Engine's Lightmass Radiosity Baker.
It's similar to render if you've used V-Ray or Corona, anything like this is similar to
those types of approaches where it's pre-baked and it is used to create high quality indirect
lighting using lighting shadow maps.
So it's always baked lighting and it cannot be altered at runtime and it has little impact
on the real-time performance.
So if you want the most optimized scenes, the bait lighting is the approach you want
to take there.
Real-time or dynamic lighting is lighting that is updated each frame.
So it's fully dynamic and can be moved around and modified at runtime.
It has no global illumination component, only the direct light and it's also expensive to
use because it affects the real-time performance because we're rendering each frame.
So Unreal Engine can use a blend of both static and dynamic lighting for archviz projects
or where assets are typically stationary, the bait static lighting is mostly used.
So say you had a scene where you used 85% static lighting, maybe 15% dynamic lighting
and then you can have those little bits of dynamic effects where you need them, but the
majority of the scene might be static.
And then touch upon ray tracing, this type of lighting is used as real-time global illumination
updated with all lights to set to movable.
So if they are animated, the global illumination GI updates on the fly.
The main lighting types, when we were looking at our place actors tab, which is the place
actors section, you'll see that the lights has its own tab as we touched upon before
where you can find the directional lights, point lights, spotlights, rect lights, just
a rectangle light and a skylight.
So these are the main different types of lighting that you'll have access to.
You can use a directional light for something like a sunlight or a moonlight.
And again, with each one of these light properties in the details panel, then you can modify
any properties.
Maybe you want to change the color or the shadow color that they're creating.
Maybe you want to change the intensity or even the rotation of the sunlight.
You can do all that through the details panel.
The point lights, single points of light in a scene.
And you can also edit these to extend the capsule.
So by default, point lights come with a spherical radius and you can actually change the point
light to be more of a cylindrical radius if you want it to be more like a fluorescent
tube light, for example.
So point lights have their own functionality and very powerful.
And maybe for a lot of the time, you might have lots of point lights in a scene.
Maybe you have a hundred point lights in the scene and maybe, you know, eighty five of
the point lights are statically lit.
And then you have, you know, the fifteen remaining that are dynamically lit.
And the important thing about both point lights and spotlights as we move on to spotlights,
you don't want too many overlapping dynamic spotlights or point lights.
So if you're using dynamic lighting, make sure the dynamic point lights are spaced apart
and they're not all too crumped together and overlapping each other with their radiuses.
So talking about spotlights, spotlights are very similar functionality as point lights,
but they just are more in a cone shape and they spot the light and then similar with
a rectangle light.
So you can have this box light that is useful for maybe archviz projects or anything that
you're doing that you need a big wall light essentially.
And then you got the skylight, which is a HDR image based ambient light, which just
gives you an overall lift to the scene.
So if we're looking at a daylight setup, the main components here, we have direct light,
we have sun, we have skylight and we have the sky sphere or dome mesh visuals.
So other components might be a light mass importance volume, a post-process volume,
atmospheric, you know, the fog or sky atmosphere or the sphere reflection captures, which will
process any reflective surfaces and create the relevant reflections for those surfaces.
So you can see a really nice diagram here of all these different components kind of
layered in to create the intended result that you want.
And so you use a combination of all the different lights to create your scenes.
So just to give those lights a little bit more context, if we're in our scene here,
I'm going to speed up my camera and I'm going to zoom out a little bit to give us more view
here.
So you'll see that the angle of the shadows, for example, is coming from this chair.
Now in your outliner, you'll be able to find the different lights if you've choose a custom
preset.
You might have more properties than this depending on the Unreal template, especially in Unreal
5, you'll have the daytime real time components here as well.
But if we're just looking at the light source, for example, for now, which is a directional
light, which we can drag into the scene with a directional light, just drag and drop.
For example, you can see the rotation on the yaw.
So as I change the rotation, you'll see the sky, the sun moving rotation.
So I could rotate this to a different direction, for example, if I wanted to change the pitch
to get deeper shadows, for example, I want to just undo that value.
It's on 66, so let's call it minus 80 for now.
And then you'll see the sun rising, so minus 40 might give a deeper shadow.
So you can see already that the sun is almost setting in the sky.
And then maybe I scroll down and change the light color to more like a warmer evening
hue, for example.
So that's essentially a directional light.
And then we've got the skylight here, which again, we can give it an overall color, we
can show how it affects the world.
You can change the intensity in any one of these.
We've got the post-process volume as well, if you want to change any post-processing
effects.
And then a light mass importance volume can be found from the place actors.
And you only really need to use a light mass importance volume if you're using baked lighting.
So if you want your scene to be baked and pre-rendered, what you can do is you can place
this volume in your scene.
So you can just drag and drop the importance volume.
It comes in as a small cube for now.
And if you scroll down to the brush settings here, you can make these boxes bigger, depending
on the scene, and only highlight the main bits of areas that you need lighting in.
And it basically says to Unreal, control this scene and just only focus on the lighting
within this box, and everything else can just be rendered usually.
So including your light mass importance volume for baked lighting is also useful.
And then just touch upon the point light and the skylight here.
I'll zoom in, and we have a point light, which we can move around the scene.
It's dynamic by default, and it's casting nice shadows.
We can maybe change the intensity or the color or the radius.
So you may want to bring the radius down so it's a smaller light or a bigger light.
Again, just playing with some of these properties will be the most beneficial, I think.
And so the main thing to take away from these lights are the mobility here, which we were
referring to before.
So you can either have static lighting where it gets baked in, and this light will then
not be able to move at runtime.
If I have movable, this is fully dynamic so I can animate this in my scene.
For example, I can move it around and create real-time shadows, again, based on those lighting
types that we spoke about.
But the important note here is a stationary light option.
And if we hover over it, a stationary light will only have shadowing and bounce light
from static geometry baked by light mass.
So part of this light is baked, but all of the lighting will be dynamic.
So it can change color, it can change intensity.
So it can't move, but it can allow partially-baked lighting, and it can also change at runtime.
So if we wanted to move this light...
So say we didn't want to move the light around the scene, but it was just there, but we did
want to change this light from orange to blue at runtime, we could do that with a stationary
light.
It's worth noting the three different light types, and by default, you probably want static.
If you do want movable, just make sure you're using these sparingly.
And stationary is a nice balance between the two if you want some dynamic elements, but
you don't need to move it around.
So hopefully that helps give a good overview of the different lighting types inside of
Unreal.